people in Gaza are been forced to use
sea water to clean themselves wash their
clothes and clean the
dishes this is a result of Israel's
Siege which restricted the supply of
water food Fuel and Medicine into the
Palestinian Enclave in response to
hamas's deadly attacks on October
7 the World Health Organization said
that more than 2 million gazans have to
get by on just 3 L of water per day for
drinking cooking and washing that's just
1/5 of the absolute minimum of 15 L
needed for basic survival according to
the
who gaza's Water Crisis began well
before the current conflict between
Israel and Hamas most of gaza's fresh
water comes from a shallow aquafer which
was contaminated with sewage and
seawater even before the war the UN has
said that as much as 96 6% of it is not
fit for human consumption so gazans had
to rely on unregulated private water
tankers and desalination plants for
drinking water there are three major
desalination plants while some of the
water is purchased from
Israel years of conflicts worsen the
already inadequate water
infrastructure in 2007 Israel and Egypt
imposed a blockade on Gaza after Hamas
took over power in the strip
that severely restricted the entry of
materials to repair and maintain Water
Systems then Israel ordered a total
Siege of Gaza after the Hamas attacks
and and Maz and
and s in the aftermath of the assault
Israel also turned off water pipelines
in late October Israeli officials said
that water was flowing through two of
the three p pipelines as fuel started to
run out two of the three desalination
plants in Gaza had to shut
down the last desalination plant still
in operation was only working at 5%
capacity in late
October all Wastewater plants in Gaza
are shut down due to the lack of power
resulting in raw sewage flooding the
streets since mid- October more than
30,000 cases of diarrhea have been
reported
according to the
wh over half of those are among children
under 5 years old the un's children's
agency warns that in Conflict areas
children under five are 20 times more
likely to die of diseases linked to
diarrhea than to
[Music]
violence long hes of people waiting to
fill Jerry cans are now common place
across the territory as water becomes
increasingly scarce the amount of water
on which Garin rely on now is a fraction
of the wh recommended range of 50 to 100
l a
day and it's negligible compared to what
people in Israel consume on average
every day according to a un
report
the Israeli military said Gaza has
sufficient Water Supplies as well as
access to solar power and Diesel it
accused Hamas of limiting civilians
access to those vital resources Hamas
denies
this what Gaza really needs according to
humanitarian organizations is fuel to
restore
power since the conflicts began on
October 7 Israel allowed only half a
tanker of fuel to enter The besieged
Enclave via the Rafa border crossing
with Egypt fuel here in Gaza is
absolutely everything because without
fuel we do not have generator we do not
have functioning Bakery you do not have
a functioning hospital um and you cannot
pump
water in mid November the UN said
200,000 Garin lost AC to clean water
after its two water distribution
contractors stopped working due to the
lack of
fuel some Aid trucks have entered Gaza
in recent weeks but the UN says they are
not bringing in nearly enough fresh
water